they went on and won the Stanley Cup did the
Blues their first in team history and Craig
buuy still the bench boss behind the blues
bench Runway here in St Louis and the Hawks
control the opening draw moving it away to
the left wing boards and Hayes got it back
left point to Scott perunovich now right Point
here's perunovich walking it through the Deep
slot a long wrist shot in and out of the glove of
morzac Puck cleared Away by vasic and all the way
down 9 seconds left on the blues Power Play
The Penalty kill continues to look good for
the Blackhawks not giving away those seam passes
cross siiz passes getting sticks in lanes and when
Peter mzx had to make the stop no rebounds Robert
bza with a lead pass here the blues on the attack
and shot they [Applause] score Matias lafier with
his first goal of the preseason excuse me scoring
the goal for for St Louis and the blues take a
one- nothing lead that's a miscommunication on
defense going back the other way and alexandr
makes him pay for it he's coming off a strong
game on Thursday night with an assist now there
you saw at a fall down in the corner cough up the
puck the blues back up ice Jordan cyu from
the right Circle couldn't get a clean shot
away Hawks take the puck back Colton dock Center
Ice cross to reel over the blues line to kinsky
tried to hand it into the high slot and did but
right there was a blue waiting and that's bvic
pavle bvic the former Ranger dumping the puck
down behind the Hawk net kenski tried to spin
it around and out picked off by the blues here's
kyou he got moric down and out f it out in front
thas shoots and [Applause] [Music] scores
it's two nothing Blues 527 into the hockey
game there's a reason why this Top Line is so
good it starts in the breakout the Hawks fail
to clear it and then just some really pretty
passing Jordan kyou threads the needle great
job keeping that puck in the zone and just
before that off a face off did a nice job at
getting a shot through and on net Alex vasic
looks like he's had some jump made some great
plays on the PK so it's the little details there
too that coaches are looking for a little bit more
important than the score of this game obviously
with it not being a regular season here's Colton
doc breaking in the Blue Zone to the [__]
couldn't get a clean shot away a followup shot
reel shoots he scores Lucas REO let it rip into
the top of the Blues net and the Blackhawks get
one on the board they Trail St Louis two to one
with 559 now left in Period number one few nice
plays defensively they started to get some chances
and then doc cutting into the middle doesn't get
the initial one but it pulls Bennington out of
position as he tries to make a play on the puck
and that opens [Music] up should be some great
matchups well the boys have a period under their
belts here let's see what they do in Period number
two they win the opening draw got to love it Hawks
did a nice moment of silence butt kiss as well
so he's felt all over his presence in Chicago
Chicago sports legend here's neeker into the hawk
with a shot he scores off of a two-on-one Break
by the Blues they came up ice pretty quickly and
took advantage it's now 3-1 St Louis yeah Jordan
Bennington does a great job clearing this Puck
out and unfortunately both D are caught up ice
just a miscommunication between Zev and Anders Bor
finds himself on that weak side what a great story
he was last season scoring on his first shift in
San Jose right after the emotional loss of Patrick
Kane and there's got with the chance put it in
front Hardman shoots that's blocked and the other
way come the Blues play opens up a bit neighbors
to Center to Hayes over the hawk line to Neighbors
in front with a backand big save by mazic down
in the butterfly position the drop the puck the
blues get it crew from the point to Thomas right
Point KW deep [__] kyou left Circle closing in
put it in front came back to kyou tough angle shot
stop rebound Thomas shoots and scores for Robert
Thomas this is his fifth goal of the preseason
and is second in this game it's another Power
Play goal and the blues extend their lead to 3
to one between kyou and bich zv does a great job
initially blocking it with his skate but Thomas
reads that one all the way and a pass up the left
wing kachuk off his stick Into the Blue Zone
kachuk took it back behind the net thanks it
out to the right point kinsky to Boris kachuk
rolling through the high slot bris shoty scores
Big B let it rip from the high slot it may have
hit somebody on the way through but the Hawks have
cut the blues lead in half now at 4-2 simple play
puts it on net catches Bennington by surprise and
it certainly hits something I don't know if Joey
Anderson got a piece of it but it redirected up
enter the hawk Zone ahead of everybody but moric
got to the puck winds it up the left wing here's
and twistle Into the Blue Zone moving to shoots he
scores oh what a an individual effort by McKenzie
and twistle and it happened on a delayed penalty
the Hawks were going to get a power play back
the other way McKenzie an whistle just a little
stutter step to his backand and he uses that big
body creates that separation he needs right there
pulls it back oh beautiful right around the toe
of Jordan Bennington glassic Into the Blue Zone
left wing Corner centers picked off by the blues
and they're back up ice on a two-on one b nage
through Center ice over the Haw line left wing
floats a saucer pass in front to kyou who directs
it on goal and mazic is down with a butterfly save
his Top Line has made the Hawks have their hands
full in the dzone that next shift after a goal so
important Hawks Hawks come back up ice three on
two gust to the line dumping it down behind the
net and CI finished his check on Rosen Hawks get
the puck back kachuk in the left wing Corner the
gust back of the net he'll back into the corner
sweep it to Kaiser right Point walking it through
the Deep slot gave it over to CI CI right Circle
snaps it on goal blocker save made by Bennington
head to Walker into the Haw Zone deine in the
corner rammed into the glass with a nice body
checked by Zev he's been a little bit physical
here tonight now borzo long wrist shot from the
point blocked in the slot and Gutman the other
way for the Hawks near the end of his shift he'll
stick the puck down the boards Into the Blue
Zone ortuso with a quick flip head to Nathan
Walker put it in for a hot net bu dke with a back
hand a nice save made by Peter morzac he got just
enough of that one to knock it wide but you can
see right there Kaiser just gets tripped up loses
his footing and Brett cini trying to make a play
defensively goes diving into the net which maybe
saves a goal the blues had a wide open look right
there but good to see cen's okay experience last
season and he's been a real bright spot in every
game he's been in to zit now zit pokes it up the
board CI Rosen took the puck away for the blues
that's lav ver moving it around to the line here's
cor Krug with a rest shot save rebound score
Jake neighbors top of the hawk grease picked up
the rebound off of the shot that originated from
the high slot and back hands it past moric and
the blues have a two-goal lead once again first
minute of the period was spent in the defensive
end Hawks couldn't get a change you have tired
players out there chasing the puck around St
Lewis had some nice passes East West nothing
really went through so Tory Krug puts one on
net here's Anders Bor through Center and in over
the blues line stopping in the right circle to
the slot Johnson fires off the crossbar Hofer
was looking for it across the board and I love
Charlie obviously too all right an empty net on
the Hawks in Nathan Walker fires he hit the post
it's hard to do yeah loose Puck from the near
boards alexandr who already has a goal tonight
gra it out of there the puck slides beside
the net Krug will backand it out to Center
Ice n seconds left as kinsky is back to get it
quick pass ahead to Gutman put it into the Blue
Zone Tucker will take it behind the net and the
heart will sound that the hockey game and the
pre-season